[موسيقى]
الإسكندرية هي ثاني مدينة في مصر ،
ولكن حوالي 100 قبل الميلاد كانت تضم أكبر
عدد من السكان على وجه الأرض
لقرون ، وقد ترك الزائرون من الهند إلى
إنجلترا بصماتهم على
مشهد الطهي المتنوع في الإسكندرية
عندما يسافر الناس معهم لتناول الطعام
وهذا هو سبب وجودهم  الكثير من التأثيرات
هنا ليس فقط من بلدان البحر الأبيض المتوسط
ن أيضًا من شرق آسيا من
لأطباق الراقية إلى الوجبات السريعة ، تق
م الإسكندرية للزائرين خيارات لا حصر لها ول
ن للحصول على طعم أصيل حقًا لل
دينة ، لا تنظر إلى أب
د من الأسماك وهذا هو ما تفعله لي
ى هسابالا وميا ني
ر.  من القاهرة ، أود
أن أحضر قاربًا لأجد
أنني أعتقد أنني سأكون قرصانًا رائعًا في عام
2016 ، بدأ الزوجان
في تنظيم جولات الطعام في القاهرة
والتي أصبحت ناجحة جدًا لدرجة أنهما
تتفرعان هنا
وسيكون تسليط الضوء على الطهي في الإسكندرية
ضروريًا
لهما  أحدث تشكيلة للمأكولات البحرية في
الإسكندرية متنوعة للغاية لأنه من الواضح أنك
حصلت على
المصدر الرئيسي للمأكولات البحرية بشكل صحيح و  إن
تناول وجبة من المأكولات البحرية هنا
هو نوع من الحدث ، فهو ليس مجرد
وجبة عادية قد تتناولها بشكل يومي
لا أستطيع أن أصفها ، وآمل فقط
أن يرى الناس
وجهي لأنها نقطة جذب النجوم في المدينة ،
وإيجاد المطعم المثالي هو
من الأهمية بمكان بالنسبة لجولة ليلى وميا الغذائية الجديدة
، ولا يوجد مكان أفضل يعكس
علاقة حب المدينة بالمأكولات البحرية
أكثر من بالبا التي وصلنا إليها للتو في
بالبا ، أحد أشهر أماكن المأكولات البحرية
في الإسكندرية ،
نعم الجميع يعرف ذلك ، نعم الجميع
يقودون كل الطريق من جميع
أنحاء مصر إلى  تعال إلى هنا اليوم ، سنحصل على
بعض المأكولات البحرية الرائعة ونحن
متحمسون للغاية
كما هو الحال مع معظم مدن البحر الأبيض المتوسط
ث يعتبر الروبيان والحبار من المأكولات الأساسية هنا ، ك
ا سيشاهد رواد المطعم أوجه تشابه وأ
باق مثل toggin the f
sh stew مماثلة لتلك الموجودة في كل
كان من إسبانيا إلى  اليونان
ولكن zungari هو أحد التخصصات المصرية ، إن
sungeti هي في الأساس طريقة للطبخ ،
لذا فأنت تضعها في شكل فراشة ولكنك
تحشوها أيضًا بالخضروات فتفتحها بالفعل.
م ظهرها بدلاً من
معدتها ،
هذا ما يجعلها
مميزة
عن الطريقة المصرية في الطهي ، لكن
الجزء الأكثر أهمية في تناول المأكولات البحرية ليس
ما يتم طلبه ولكن مع من لأن
سر مشهد الطهي في المدينة
هو أهلها وربما
التجربة الإسكندرية الأكثر أصالة لجميع الذين
اجتمعوا معًا على طبق من المأكولات البحرية الجيدة